[Music]
have you guys heard of this comedian
named Jovan T Carter nope he's from New
Orleans there's a cool whatever he did I
completely support it
yeah this guy he was born with a genetic
skin disease that affects the growth of
teeth hair and sweat glands and it's
associated with distinctive facial
features such as a prominent forehead
missing teeth thick lips and a flattened
bridge of the nose I need to see this
man yeah I'll show you in a second I'm
picturing the got him no that was
different person yeah okay
I'm picturing a dolphin yeah but this
guy is a 19 year old comedian he went
viral when he was just eight years old
oh wow a photo of his went viral and not
until he was 16 that's when he realized
he could make a living out of off of his
looks and that's when he started doing
comedy types of videos so I'm gonna show
you guys a oh I've seen this dude oh he
looks like a filter yeah I've seen them
a lot of stuff here we go he's always
doing [ __ ] with his mouth oh it is plain
what what oh I have seen him oh my god I
see now already bro I got a new
oh [ __ ] oh so he collab with another guy
the neck guy he's a little neck guy
that's great that's dope
so he treats him like he's a [ __ ] exactly
he was saying that he he had always
gotten bullied growing up and like
growing up in New Orleans it's already a
tough place to grow up in and he had it
even worse because of his genetic skin
they got the Mardi Gras is over there
all these people with the beads talking
[ __ ] to him so his joints are like super
flexible huh I don't know or is it just
in his face but there is a famous
painting of an old man doing that with
his face yeah does he have that oh maybe
yeah cuz I was like I see there it was
like like what about the screen guy does
he have that who the screen the famous
picture it's a real person is it no I
don't think so for the cool being a lot
about javante Carter's story is that he
turned his bullies into fans so he was
like now like hit the people that would
bully him growing up like now they
follow him they like are his biggest
fans
that's dope yeah yeah it's cuz they were
insecure as [ __ ] you see the
collaboration that he's been doing like
there's a longneck kid and the wide net
kid and then there there's gonna they're
gonna have the Avengers of different
body face guys it's like it's like a
modern-day circus freak show but they're
embracing it you know yeah we're kind of
embracing it will today yeah the guys at
Venice yeah the circus used to do that
to them which is kind of cool make money
up late yeah yeah true true true true
cuz no matter what
I think humans are gonna be attracted to
this cuz it's just so bizarre like it's
crazy it will always be carnies
yeah they better make money on it man
it's it's make money off of that
uniqueness
[ __ ] dude I was a kid when the kid in
the class who could like [ __ ] to the
elbow up sit down or whatever was like a
celebrity
da truth even the kids like
you can supposed to say my eyelids or
the kids I could do the alphabet while
burping and [ __ ] no you can't or the
kids with the Audi bellybuttons weirdo
shoes or even those girls would be like
touch their [ __ ] head with their with
their foot yeah you get over their head
I'm just like stretchy and then later on
in life I was like that'd be fun to [ __ ]
that person yeah no that's true
opportunity gymnastics chick I didn't
really they come when they're a feet
behind their neck yeah but see I didn't
realize how many things I missed out on
sexualizing later cuz that first were
like whoa you're a freaking later your
lives
oh you could spread it preform oh yeah
you can you want for your eyelids oh how
do you sexualize the boy that could do
that for girls I don't know girls if a
guy can do that sexy I'm just like are
those guys that can listen like go
around like how well from a girl's point
of view is there anything that like was
kind of weird for a guy when you're a
kid that you're like oh that's pretty
sexy you know guys it's like like like
what Steve was saying the girl that
could put the legs over their head took
advantage out in a sexy way
here something like that would dudes the
big tongue guys like Karen oh yeah are
you a big chunk Queen he just taught me
about size means the other night while
we're watching love island and she was
telling me that she thought somebody was
a size panel
what's a size size it's like it's like a
girl it's like that's her a thing like
she only she's obsessed with like big
dick pictures you know I'm saying just
because it's a big dick you know like
she'll only mess would do to be other
huge dick how do they find out
beforehand
oh you find out you just talk to them
maybe you could put you up on a day and
it was
yeah kiss any you press the dick and
you're like okay yeah sighs Queen Queen
you tell the we're short on Queen Kings
out like this Oh God Wow hey check slap
it like it's a [ __ ] Buick that
doesn't work or staticky TV tone Queen
oh yeah
javante saying that he now has built up
his fan base and he earns about two
thousand and three thousand dollars per
post Wow and he suggests that he earns
around six figures yearly that's so good
yes Instagram really changed the game
you know in terms of being able to make
a living out of either like just being
really hot sore looking different or you
know [ __ ] doing anything really you know
there's like it's so weird cuz there's
an audience for anything not only is it
yeah you could be in Venice Beach is
doing cool dance tricks and like an
audience will form mm-hm like you don't
know where you could be mm-hmm I used to
follow y'all follow bread faith is Asian
girl who uh she looks like bread he has
a couple hundred thousand followers and
no she's like yeah it's loaf of bread
and she smashes her face into it yeah we
talked about it and you know it's bread
so it's like the table under the bread
no just smush it with her face she's
it's like a fetish things uh just to get
like a waistband right I hope she eats
it does she do like sourdough seems kind
of tough she does all types of yeah
sourdough like yeah does she refer to
herself as bread face
that's her Instagram name bread face I
think I think wonder Wonder Bread white
bread probably be the best yeah oh yeah
Hawaiian bread Hawaiian bread sweet
bread yeah
red no I want some bread potato burger
with the wine sweet bread oh hell yeah
yes I love like taking any leftover meat
and just putting make a little Hawaiian
bread sandwich the leftover king man so
good I could just eat Hawaiian bread by
itself we just had lunch by the way guys
yeah Hawaiian breads delicious though
we're just really talking about it not
even being that hunger mmm
appreciate it yeah so
javante this is a quote of his uh so
when he he says that he entered he
refuses to entertain the trolls and he
takes the high road whenever he responds
because there's still people that are
very cruel saying that he should have
died at birth we need a hook his core is
I'll respond you need to die always
follow me positivity by liking one of
their photos or the comment to show them
I'm not stooping down to their luck what
a dope person yeah he's dope better than
me because I'll reply with some leg
[ __ ] you you know what's crazy is all of
us post so much content right when we
had like most a lot of our channel's
open and we have Instagram we have
everything at any given day every single
day someone's talking [ __ ] to us yeah
yeah crazy but someone's also loving us
true every single day wait way more love
you even look at this video right now
maybe everyone's hating on us right now
say it 300 something like there's
there's a hundred thousand people
watching probably so who cares about one
percent true nobody even bother you the
heat is like a 1% another 1% because
they like let's say we have 200 comments
all right yeah they hate is only like 20
let's is that go yeah so yeah but that's
why you can't let that [ __ ] get to you
yeah it's pointless
it is the cool thing is we have somebody
telling us [ __ ] you every day like
nobody has that unless you're someone
important that's what makes you a born
if someone is like willing we talk [ __ ]
to you every [ __ ] day they're willing
to hate you so that's [ __ ] amazing
and then you're applying they're like oh
dude I just wanted your attention I'm
oh no I wasn't looking like that guys
[ __ ] around man so much the big fans
give a plan thank you see any picture
your whites wife's feet guys are [ __ ]
buddy-buddy and [ __ ] hey man I follow
you I follow your wife and wiki for you
my wife is on wiki feed is yours oh no
you guys don't we give you a my own wiki
feet No hey Bart put them up let's see
if we can get you on there yeah yeah
give him the special foot good package
your wiki feet submission would you be
seriously bro oh you've got a little
blister on the pinkie is this a bit hey
Bart just be honest a bit right now cuz
we're trying to get your please so the
other ones the other ones is that this
special no we can fit a Warren this
one's fun bar you're trying to get on
[ __ ] wiki feet I had a bucket war for
too long way better
you're all you're not on wiki if you did
forget it just forget it I think so it's
gonna take a year at healing for that
I thought wiki P people like the smell
some do some don't if there was
smell-o-vision they'd probably be like
oh yeah some people like step on my head
and some of you were like let me lick
them ye and some people like can you
step on my balls please yeah what you
are you Joe I don't like I don't like
free I like I like feet in shoes shoes
you can't see it like that please any
coming I do like it like shoes would you
have sex with a hooker speed mmm no not
even I had to think of it you know
there's feet board yeah we've heard the
guys it's so funny the way they get the
feet and then they clap it together and
then they they they're so horny but the
girl is literally doing like this okay
they're doing this
that guy's [ __ ] the foot like this
have you thought about softest part of
your foot is though it is yes I imagine
for a guy it'd be poor what's with that
part though where they think moan about
it I why I know that's what it yeah yeah
I can't live my feet porn anymore yeah
if I have a choice between a mouth and a
vagina
I'm not [ __ ] feet and coming on
[ __ ] feet what it's you only that you
thought you'd come on her feet
what do you got against feet I would go
for nothing overfeed saying ask her to
[ __ ] bend over or something now I
would not [ __ ] feet I can't [ __ ] for you
I'm not a feet [ __ ]
feet are too warm especially just so
have a guy talking yeah would you get
toe banged I would try it I would try a
melon dick I'm trying a lot no I'm
talking about would you let a toe into
your vagina
oh no what kind of foot slot are using
condom on what kind of foot song is that
doujins oh I don't want it in me I want
to [ __ ] a foot like bad a dick you said
that you would let a dick [ __ ] your feet
yes that's a foot [ __ ] yours what's up
[ __ ] your feet cheers a [ __ ] foot so
don't forget to everybody
Bart is not a is it I'm a beauty guru
[ __ ] toe in their vagina I know but
I'm trying to help to have rebrand right
now huh and that's under Brandi poorly
[Music]